well we've talked today about
students beginning in their careers
we've talked about correspondence ending
their careers we've talked about the
names
aj liebling and if stone have come up
one of the things i most admire about
the profession is it has allowed some
people
to say what they mean and to stand by it
to live by it
lewis lapham editor of harper's
subscribed yesterday's
new york observer is america's favorite
grouchy magazine editor
i don't i don't think of him that way i
think of him as an iconoclast i think
him as a trenchant observer
someone who says exactly what he's what
he means and says it
extremely well and someone who provokes
me uh and sometimes
elucidates sometimes provokes but i
think that's the very best tradition
of american journalism and so ladies and
gentlemen i give you lewis slapham
well i'm delighted to be here i see many
friends in the room and i'm sorry i
didn't get the piece out of mr frank
but i was i thought i was going to come
and talk to a very small lunch and tell
old stories about
the days when i was a foreign
correspondent and so forth but
bill persuaded me to talk about the
new american ruling class which is a
subject to which i and how does
journalism fit
into the new order so
i'm not a marxist and i'm not a
revolutionary i'm
sometimes i'm not even a grouch but the
i know that the the word class arouses
suspicion and uneasiness in an american
audience and
i have no objection to a ruling class no
country can exist without a ruling class
that was true in rome in the first
century that was true in the united
states in 1787 that was true britain at
the zenith
empire and it's true now so the only
question in my mind is what kind of a
ruling class
uh what what's the name what's its
nature what
what what's the character and what's its
worth made to what
specifications and with what's uh
passions or objectives in mind and it
seems to me that the
american ruling class or governing class
or
possessing class whatever you want to
call it
my favorite term for it is equestrian
class because that is an old roman term
the rank was for sale for 400
000 sister sees in in rome in the first
century a.d and the
and and the governing class in america
is
it's a rank that is for sale that's
also always been true in the united
states but
something has happened to that class
over the last
50 years i think i think it is no longer
a specifically american
class i i think it's
lost its interest in politics
and i don't think it has much use for
an intelligent press and
you now will ask me who are we talking
about
and the figures vary and numbers of
other writers have written on this
subject that
bill grider has written about it kevin
phillips
christopher lash michael lind
essentially we're talking about
is that one or two percent of the
american population
that owns 90 percent of the nation's
wealth
and 75 percent of its capital assets
it's an oligarchy uh
it's not a large percentage but it's a
fairly large
absolute number i mean maybe we're
talking about two million
people perhaps essentially these are the
people who write the laws who write the
news
run the schools direct the corporations
own the media on and on the banks
the rich and the servants of the rich
lind michael lind in his book that he
published last
summer called the american nation uh
refers to what he calls the
donor party the donor party
is the group of no more than two hundred
thousand people in the united states
who give political campaign gifts in
excess
of five thousand dollars to become
a candidate you must be
first elected by the donor party
that is the beginning and end
of the american democracy it's 200 000
people
from because if you don't have money you
you don't unless you're steve forbes
or perrault you have no you don't even
appear
on television the another way of
describing the
the the oligarchy or the equestrian
class would be to just think of the
shoppers on madison avenue or rodeo
drive or the residence of the zip code
section in new york
in new york new york one zero zero two
one
which is this narrow golden rectangle in
the city of manhattan
where the annual income is something
like two billion dollars a year
income within that one zip code section
another way to think of it would be the
way that the public broadcasting
network thinks of it which is um
i did a book show on television for a
couple of years for pbs
and there the the pbs number which is
like the harper's number
for the total universe of
americans that is that makes the market
for the trade list of the new york times
books for magazines like harper's new
yorker foreign affairs
for the documentaries that appear on pbs
for most of the leading policy journals
and so forth we're talking
about no more than two million people
if that many that's the whole universe
now the people that uh essentially live
within that universe
run the schools own the banks write the
laws and so forth
it's the view from the box seats
and the first thing that's changed in
the last 50 years
is the sense of responsibility
i believe maybe i'm a romantic but i do
believe that 50 years ago
this class felt some degree of
responsibility
toward the lower borders
there was a sense that privilege
entailed
obligation there was the attitude was
derived in part from the
attitude of the british ruling class the
late part of the 19th century
from whom we the americans picked up the
white man's burden in the direction of
rudyard kipling
who wrote that poem as a matter of fact
there's a campaign speech for teddy
roosevelt
but that attitude is also confirmed by
the
american victories in world war ii
and i i happen to have been thinking
great deal about this subject lately
because i am writing a book about the
social and intellectual history of yale
university
over the second half of the american
century begin
1950 to the year 2000 the american
century as you know is a phrase coined
by henry luce
yale 1919 uh former chairman of the yale
daily news and so forth and the
whole sense of american empire american
primacy
american supremacy american obligation
is very much in place it
at yale in the 1950s which is when i was
there as an undergraduate
and several of the professors in both
the english department and the history
department
were recruiters for the cia the
sense that the of a noble mission
of bringing the light to a darkened
world
the careers was very much part of the
meal year and
then as yale now is in the business of
making
the american equestrian class that is
why
one pays 26 27 000
a year to send a child to either yale
harvard princeton
or the other universities that do this
sort of thing
the people at
in the 50s identified themselves with an
inter with an american commonwealth
there was um an american
ideal it was an american idea there was
a sense
of obligation i don't think that the
current um kids
the the ones that i know at new haven
or the our current uh oligarchy has the
same feeling at
all i think that
the members of the american equestrian
class today
inclined to think of themselves as
align themselves with an international
economic
order rather than an american
commonwealth
there's very little patriotism in
in this among the people that i'm
talking about
they have more in common with their
peers uh
their economic peers in england japan
or germany than they do with their
with a run of the mill americans in
omaha or sin city
and it you see it in the character of
somebody like richard nixon
who was very much at home with the shah
of iran
or ferdinand marcos
or noriega people of that those are the
kind of people that he
liked could talk to understood
deep fear and hatred of the ordinary
american citizen
corporations the american corporations
today receive
much if not most of their income from
abroad
coca-cola now no longer has a domestic
division
it's a world company and the uh
so they're not thinking in terms of the
of an american nationalist
economics a lot of as you this is also
obviously true of the movie industry
which without foreign sales
cannot afford to pay the kinds of
salaries they now pay it's also true of
our
banking industries and airlines and so
on
so it's an international
that economic uh world order and this is
very clear this is i sound like buchanan
but
buchanan is right in this i i don't
think this is a matter of opinion i
think this is a matter of
sheer statistics that you can see it
with
nafta you can see it in any number of
ways you i i saw it most clearly
the year that the challenger exploded
the six months after the
challenger exploded at t and ge
were called to testify before the senate
foreign relations committee because the
cold war was still going on
and 18c and ge had decided to send up
their newest satellite
on the soviet rocket it was the only
rocket
going and the
foreign relations committee took took
this very seriously and said
you can't do this this is trading with
the enemy and so on this is our most
sophisticated
technology and so forth and so on and
the two corporations said we really
don't care what you think senator
it's not important because this is about
money
and if we don't send it up on the
russian rocket we're going to lose
to the french we can't afford to lose to
the french
and you could make the speech to you
know your friends at the council on
foreign relations but
no and goodbye um another
way of looking at the
increasing isolation of the american
equestrian order
is in the move to the suburbs that's
everybody a lot of other people have
written about that but we now have
a country that is becoming increasingly
feudal in its organization we have
the united states spends 20 billion
dollars a year
on public law enforcement that includes
all forms of public law enforcement city
county sheriff's fbi
justice department so forth we spend 40
billion dollars on
private law enforcement again it's the
the retreat from the public
realm privatization of everything
the private is 50 years ago
the notion of the public sector the
public sphere
the public commonwealth would have
connoted a good
today in most usages
the word public connotes filth
squalor incompetence bad housing
full politicians and leaking brains and
so forth and the word
private is associated with the clear
crowd streams of colorado and all good
things flow from the private sector
as opposed to the public sector that is
a
something that has happened in in 50
years
another another way you see the
withdrawing is the sense of
the american sense of humor
50 years ago most of the jokes or many
of the jokes were
the have-nots making fun of the haves
this was the humor of menkin this was
the humor of the movies of the 30s this
was the humor of the new yorker
in in the 30s and so on today it's
reversed the humor is the haves making
fun of the have-nots
it's the humor of the david letterman
show it's the humor of pj o'rourke
it's the period it's the hero it's the
it's the humor of the uh
hip movies of uh quentin tarantino
i happen to find it very repellent but
nevertheless it is
the the tone that's in place
second thing that's happened in the last
50 years
and corollary to what i'm talking about
in terms of the character of the
american equestrian class is
the absence of interest in history or
politics
the uh one would have expected
circa 1950 1955
even as late as 1960 that the
people who enjoyed economic privilege
would also be interested
in the history of the united states uh
interested in
the intellectual content of the media
the newspapers
i went to work at the new york herald
tribune in 1960 which was the paper then
owned by john a whitney
a leading republican
presence in in new york and on that wing
of the republican party
and he his ownership of the
tribune at the time was in the line of
pulitzer who was the democrat or greeley
who was a republican or even colonel
mccormick
of the chicago papers who was extreme
what we would today call a stream right
but whitney's interest was primarily
uh tonight a political one he hadn't had
an idea he had a political idea
and the ownership of the the papers
reflected that
uh they no longer do i mean now
you would not associate i would not uh
associate the corporations that own
the networks or that own the big or the
disney company or
whatever the big media syndicates are
with a
political idea i'd associate them with
an economic idea
uh with the new international economic
world order yes but with a
with an idea that that somehow politics
mattered i wouldn't think so and and you
can see that uh
in the newspapers this morning the front
page of the times today talks about the
money likely to flow to the democratic
republican candidates for the house
in next november's election and clearly
the lines are
the same lines as dwayne andreas the
head of
adm who gives with the left hand to the
democrat and to the right hand
with a republican because it really
doesn't matter
there there is only in my view and
lots of other people's view there's only
one political party in the united states
at the moment
and the point is power the point is to
be have
connection to have access to
the committee or to the tax legislation
or to the
telecommunications bill or it it has
very little to do
with with ideas that is again a change
i think over the last 50 years
you see this at
on the stage at yale university you no
longer can study
uh political history about
american political history there are
something called cultural studies
so the history the america the telling
of the american tale has been broken
down
into telling of the black american tale
or the feminist american tale
or the ethnic native american american
tale
and so forth and so on and you can go
through the entire
you can take as the there is no
curriculum
that went in the 60s but you know in
order to satisfy
the requirement for late 18th century
history united states you can take it
in domestic pewter butter churns
the plight of women on the frontier and
so forth
all interesting subjects but but
not a coherent historical
view all right if
if i'm correct then in the
two points about the
american equestrian class over the last
50 years
point one being the the feeling of no
responsibility toward
the less fortunate and
to the absence of interest in either
history or politics
as as a passionate interest
then what then becomes the the function
of the press and the
again that's the parallels to me are
very similar
when i first started working for the
newspapers i my first job was a display
reporter for the san francisco examiner
in 1957 a hurst newspaper
and i was the only
ivy league person in the entire
place to use the word journalist
was would have been nobody used the word
journalist
only englishman and fops used the word
journalist
americans used the word reporter or
newspaper man
nobody was paid any money event to speak
of
and nobody expected to make any monies i
mean there was
one did not go into newspaper reporting
to become rich one came in for
probably in my case romantic ideas
growing out of the
depression and out of the
autobiographies of novelists on the
order of john o'hara and his hemingway
but the
notion was to somehow get at the truth
and tell a story
it's a romantic notion but the
there was uh and we tended
as as newspaper guys to
identify with the people in the
bleachers
not with the people in the box seat
and that changed in the middle 60s by
1967
the the ranks of the
newspaper what was the newspaper
business begins to fill up with people
from harvard and yale and princeton
the salaries begin to go up to 300 400
000
a year for television personalities
and the identification shifts from
the uh the crowd and the bleachers
to the swells in the box seats
and i now think that's where we are i
think we now have by and large
present company accepted a courtier
press a a i think of most of the major
news persons in the united states and i
think of rosencrantz and guildenstern
in shakespeare's hamlet the idea that
somebody like bob woodward is presented
as an investigative journalist
is a joke that can only be appreciated
by somebody who remembers
uh what the what investigative
journalism was that
and the i turned down as the editor of
harper's magazine
all the president's men in 19 whatever
it was 73
because there's not a single name source
and i mean i said okay that's gossip
stuff that's
great but that's not what i learned as a
as a journalist and most of his
most of what now or much of what now
passes for
um big time journalism
is that kind of whisper gossip
the dying bill casey of parts in my
shell-like year
the truth about iran contra etc etc
or in the as in uh where halberstam's
book the best and brightest
not a single name source conversations
all
invented and reconstructed it passes
in in a world that doesn't care
about history uh as truth
the um or as as as
entertainment and i i don't have to
dwell on all of that i mean but as the
in in in 1960 there was still something
called the newspaper business
literature theater movies
by 1970 all of those what were once
discrete disciplines have been
fused into something called media
we you know as the politicians become
less responsible
and like-minded so do uh
so do uh our journalists so does our
journalism i mean
to go back to the the roman example
when at the zenith of
rome's military power the returning
general would
have a triumph through the streets of
rome
standing in the chariot behind him
would come the train of captured slaves
and
elephants trophies and so forth
and but they would stand behind his
shoulder in a chariot
they would stand behind the shoulder
there would be a man who would say
remember you are mortal
today our journalists we are now the
zenith of our economic power
um the wonder of an admiring world in
many different ways
and we ride in in triumph through the
streets of
new york or washington or london and our
media
stands behind behind us
in in the chariot and says know that you
are a god
and and that's the you know essentially
that's the cover of
fortune magazine or the you know the
worship of bill gates
and so it's a very dangerous
attitude i think i think we have a less
and less
grasp of reality we now have a country
in which the
ratio between what the ceo of a
corporation makes
and the lowest paid assembly worker or
clerk in the same company the ratio is
184 to one
and even as recently as 20 years ago
duration was the ratio is 15 to 1 which
is what it is in
france england and japan and
that kind of um i've run out of time i'm
sorry i've gone too long but
but that given that kind of
world of wish reverie dream
uh the public relations man who's
sometimes difficult to tell from the
washington columnist
standing behind you in the chariot
whispering in your ear that you're a god
given that i i i can't think of a more
uh
necessary corrective
than both the art and craft of
journalism
and i'm proud to be associated with
people who
also believe that and with the six
young people who i hope will sharpen
their
pencils and go out and
do battle in the coming days thank you
we have just just a moment or two for a
question
uh i'd be interested in it seems that
the
the american embrace of a global economy
and all these things you've talked about
have created
critics of the system from a buchanan on
the right but also
for other voices on other ends of the
political spectrum and is that
what does that mean why is that
happening
i mean why are there criticisms well no
why why would it be that on there is a
from a liberal perspective there's
criticism and
also as well as from a populist or
right-wing perspective it seems to be
pretty pretty broad condemnation
well i mean there are all kinds of ways
of breaking that down i mean
there are complaints about everything i
mean one of the complaints is that the
government
is not us however we define the us it is
it is a them and not a we and and so we
go around we play the game of musical
chairs as to who is the us and to who's
them and
and by
i can't possibly answer that question in
all of its but everybody's angry because
people on both the left and the right
see that the system
that something's wrong we have a
congress
so futile that it cannot negotiate a
disarmament
treaty with its own citizens who own 200
million guns
or or we have a we we have a uh we have
a
budget debate the government shuts down
twice
in this winter on what essentially is i
mean
a balanced budget is an imaginary number
literally i mean it happens in the out
years seven years from now which of
course never happens it's it's peter pan
it's it's
we are talking about angels dancing on
the heads of pins when we're talking
about what the
budget is going to be like seven years
from now and the government shuts down
twice and people get angry at that sort
of thing every poll
shows eighty percent of the american
people want to protect the environment
and the and the people in washington
wave that one away
but you know just go right over that one
and and begin
taking down the environmental
regulations with no
reference to the supposedly
nominally sovereign people and the
nominally sovereign people
are getting very angry properly so in my
view
any other um well thank you very much
for coming you're welcome
all right